Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 14th,
2016 what's going on?
I,
why Ya?
Uh,
my voice is a little messed up here because,
uh,
you know,
I've been traveling,
traveling,
traveling.
I've been taking my vitamins as they say,
over in Europe or a gyno determines tomatoes.
Um,
Basel I don't understand why with ingredients,
you know,
everything else we pretty much pronounce,
pronounce the same as fucking Great Britain.
But when it comes to spices,
everything is different.
We say Reagan and we say Basil.
They say Organa Basel,
whatever the fuck they say,
tomato vitamins.
Um,
the only time I really experienced that in the United States as we say,
Carnegie in Pittsburgh says,
Carnegie Bill,
what are you talking about?
I don't fucking know.
I just got off of Goddamn plane and I,
uh,
watched all the football on the way out.
Oh my God.
Underrated flying on football fucking Sunday when there was too fucking games
back to back with seven fucking lead changes.
Um,
the boring NFL with their ratings down.
How great was Sunday?
Fucking amazing.
Fucking amazing man.
Um,
that Dallas,
Pittsburgh game was incredible.
Um,
and the Pittsburgh Seattle game was great.
And uh,
I know a lot of people would think like the thing,
you know what the thing I was most upset about,
it wasn't the final score.
It wasn't the,
the lack of a call on,
on the last play with Gronk.
It was the Tom Brady picture.
What the fuck was that with his hand on his hip and his other hand up underneath
his jaw.
What in the fuck was that?
That's what happens when your data's supermodel.
She's in his Goddamn me.
Or just be like,
Tom,
you're just standing there like everybody else.
You need to establish your brand,
have fun with it.
Be a little Sassy.
Um,
yes,
you're probably not gonna hear this from a lot of patriots fans,
but I love the no call at the end of the fucking game.
I am forever sticking up for quarterbacks in the NFL when it comes to their
right to be there to try and prevent a score.
You know,
you know how this all started old Jim or say out there in Indianapolis couldn't
beat the Patriots defense.
So he's the one that created the whole,
hey,
the cornerback can't even look at the receiver past five fucking yards,
you know,
so I love the no call.
I thought Gronk did that thing where he ran right into him.
He didn't quite push off,
but it was one of those gray area thinks you usually get a call on that.
I feel like 70% of the time I'll just throw that stat out there.
You know,
I don't read right.
Um,
I loved the no call.
I wish that they would do that.
Um,
but other than that,
it was just a great fucking game.
And I liked it too because Seattle is kind of just played the game rather than
doing all that peacock and around every time they do something,
there was one guy,
that fat guy,
that nose tackle for Seattle.
I was fucking dying laughing on the plate.
That first drive the Patriots had where they just went right down the field and
gave him the old right there,
Fred.
Every fucking play was positive yardage except for one.
So we had like six,
seven plays in a row or were just crushing it,
15 yards,
10 yards,
eight yards,
20 yards right down the field.
If you judged the game on that first fucking drive,
you'd be like,
oh my God,
this is going to be a fucking landslide.
Right.
And then one plate,
I think they handed it off to likely Garrett Blunt and he just runs in to the
offensive line for no gain in that fat dude stands up and he wags a finger like
mud tumble over at Belichick and the Patriots bench.
Hey,
all those other players are going to work,
but not that one.
Don't try that one.
It's the funniest shit ever to me.
But um,
you know,
it was an amazing game and I actually liked the fact that we lost to them,
even though they didn't have Bennett.
You know,
they were kind of hurt and we still lost to him and it was in our house,
you know.
Did I just say our house?
I'm sorry it was in our stadium.
Um,
it didn't bug me because if we meet them again in the playoffs,
I'd rather have lost the regular season game.
Um,
you know,
they always say that shit like,
you got a,
you always learn more during a loss.
I liked way better losing,
you know,
I think the biggest thing that fucked the 2007 Patriots undefeated regular
season Patriots was the fact that we were undefeated also.
Spygate everyone was just rooting against us.
I would have loved it so much more if we went into the playoffs 14 and two or 15
and one just to,
you know,
so everybody will didn't like,
didn't have such a chip on his shoulder to fucking play.
Um,
I can't even,
why the fuck I just made that point?
Oh,
I know why because I've seen so many times.
Like,
it's like you beat them in the regular season and then they see you a month or
two later and then they come back and beat you.
Giants did that to us.
The jets did it to us.
We beat them first.
No,
they beat us first.
Then we just steroid them at home and then a month later they beat us in the
playoffs.
And it's just kinda how it goes.
So,
uh,
I'm all right with it.
Um,
I'm still not too thrilled with our defense and uh,
can somebody,
by the way,
for the love of fucking God,
and I don't want to hear this from a fan,
I need it from a football coach.
Can somebody explain to me the prevent defense?
I know I've asked this before,
but for the love of God,
can somebody please explain to me at the half the Patriots score a touchdown
we're playing with these guys were covering,
they're not getting any big place.
We completely abandoned that.
This 59 seconds to go in the half,
we completely fucking abandoned that.
We start playing a zone defense or maybe we were playing zone up until then.
I don't know,
whatever the fuck we were doing was working.
We were in a zone defense giving them a 20 yard cushion.
Basically you can see a field goal.
Okay.
And we just,
in 59 seconds,
these fucking guys,
seven plays,
seven 75 yards in 59 fucking seconds
and the last plate for the touchdown watching that wide receiver going from one
zone to the defense to another.
You know what he look like,
you have a see when a fan just runs out on the field and he's just running by
players and they're just looking at them.
You know what I mean?
Cause it's all that's a fan security.
We'll handle that.
This fucking guy because of the prevent defense was standing by himself like a
yard out from the end zone if not on the end zone line waving his fucking arms.
I mean he might as well have been dressed in street clothes.
The level of like non coverages that is,
and I understand the concept behind the prevent defense is basically we'll give,
we'll give up the middle of the field will protect the sideline and they'll make
completions.
We'll tackle them and then they're going to somehow eat up this 59 fucking
seconds.
It never happens.
I swear to God,
I think it's a conspiracy.
It's a business move by the NFL.
It's to increase scoring slash add to the drama.
If another team is only up by one fucking score and the other team goes into a
prevent,
the game is going to end with three or four shots at the end zone or they're
going to kick a field goal to try and win it.
It just,
it.
It just doesn't fucking work.
And you know what's funny?
So we go into the fucking prevent and they go right down the field.
Give us the all right there.
Fred.
Score of fucking touchdown.
All right,
very deflating.
No Pun intended for the Patriots is if we go into the locker room.
All right,
now we've got to kick off to Seattle.
We kick off to Seattle.
We played defense.
They go three and out.
It's like,
why the fuck did we do that before the half?
Sorry.
Half of this is emotionally only half as I smoked two cigarettes two nights in a
row.
Which I can't fucking do.
Um,
I don't understand that on any fucking level.
I also don't understand
when the end of the game,
Seattle scores a touchdown.
They go up by seven points.
Why wouldn't you just kick an extra point?
Go up by eight,
you're acting like a two point conversion.
Is it done deal?
Which is isn't which we saw when Seattle went to go for it and didn't get it
right.
Am I there?
Cause I kind of looked away from the screen.
Um,
they went for two there,
right?
And they didn't get it and then they were only up by one.
Maybe I'm,
maybe I'm wrong here.
I might be wrong if that's what happened.
Can somebody explain that move that they went to go up by two,
so they'd be up by a touchdown in a field goal rather than just go on,
let's go with the fucking 90 something percent thing and kick a fucking extra
point.
Go up by eight and make the Patriots not only have to score a touchdown but then
convert a fucking two point conversion
if that is in fact what happened.
Like I said,
I was on a plane and,
uh,
you know,
there was shit to fucking look around that.
Um,
and it also kind of like,
what I like to do is I like to,
uh,
I like to listen to like ACDC and shit like that when I'm on a plane.
So I listened to like the whole flick of the switch album while I was watching
the game.
It's actually pretty fucking cool.
Um,
and also you can actually just sort of watch the game and not getting nearly as
emotional,
you know,
because when your team is losing,
you start thinking that the announcers are against your team and vice versa and
all that type of shit.
So I,
um,
I dunno,
but I thoroughly enjoyed that game.
I'm not one of those fucking fans that fucking,
you know,
his team loses and then thinks,
oh,
we got fucked and blah,
blah,
and all that bullshit.
Okay.
I don't,
uh,
I don't think that it was a fucking great game and I know you guys didn't have
Bennet and uh,
you know,
and it was great seeing two of the most fucking,
uh,
the two biggest cheetahs facing off with one another.
One guy gets all the press,
the other guy doesn't do you know,
Seattle since like 2010.
Um,
I think they recently got passed by the Redskins.
They were the most,
they had the most um,
people busted for uh,
taking roids.
You'd never know that they're in Seattle,
man.
They make coffee.
Nobody gives a fuck.
You do that where there's a little bit of foliage and all of a sudden it's a
fucking national story for fucking year and a half
because you let a cons.
Here's what the air out of a fucking ball.
It's hilarious.
It's amazing to me.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
I uh,
I also got to do one of my favorite charitable events,
um,
other than the Patrice O'neal company benefit.
Um,
tickets are on sale.
They are on sale.
I will tweet out the link again today.
It's going to be at the New York City Center,
I believe February 21st I think it's a Tuesday bill.
It'd be Kinda Nice if he had the actual fucking information wouldn't it?
Clicking on the camera,
camera coupling on the calendar.
All right,
going in.
It's,
yes,
February 21st Bam.
Um,
I got to do the,
uh,
the comics come home event and uh,
this is a really special event for me because I got to do,
I did it 20 years ago was the first time I did it and think it was at the
Orpheum and I got to meet Cam Neely,
Chris and island was there.
I got to meet Dennis leary and I mean I was literally three and a half years in
my career and um,
it was such an unbelievable event to be a part of and I went out and thank God I
,
I,
I had a good set and I remember Larry called me and left a message.
I'm so bummed I wasn't home when he called me.
This is like 20 years ago.
So I didn't have a cell phone,
had an answering machine.
And I,
you know,
I,
I actually remember listening to the message like over and over again,
and he was like,
uh,
a bill.
It's a Dennis,
uh,
just want to say thank you,
you really fucking funny and,
uh,
you fucking killed this and thank you for [inaudible],
for doing it,
right,
guide,
fuck off.
And he just hung up and I listened to it like fucking 20 times in a row was so
fucking cool.
And,
um,
and I was also in a panic like,
oh fuck,
I didn't pick up the phone when he called.
Was that my big break we would have talked to,
would have became friends.
He would open all the doors for me.
You know,
those,
those over the top panic moments that you have when you're trying to make it in
this business that you think you every,
every little thing you think you blew it.
Um,
and you actually,
what she ended up realizing is this is not one thing.
It's a series of things all just building this fucking snowball that rolls down
the hill before you finally get there.
Um,
so anyways,
so I got to do it.
And,
uh,
it was Jay laughing.
It was his first one.
He did great.
Wendy Liebman,
uh,
Lenny clock with his fucking lime green pants.
Uh,
probably going to forget some people,
Wanda Sykes,
Nick Depaulo than me than Bobby Kelly.
And uh,
that was cool cause we,
Bobby will close in and out and he's part of my standup graduation class.
And I remember when we both first got to do what we would,
we were in the Jay Larson spot,
the first guy out,
the new guy,
which is really hard because nobody knows who you are enough and you got to go
up.
And that was just the Orpheum in Larson went up at the fucking TD bank,
North Garden where the Bruins and Celtics play and he fucking killed,
look totally relaxed.
And I remember watching them going like,
I wasn't that relaxed the first time I did it and was just in a,
in a theater.
And um,
you know,
it was cool.
I had some friends in there too though.
That was their first a comedy show they'd ever been to.
And let me,
let's just say they saw the gamut of everything that could possibly happen when
you go on stage.
Man,
it was a fucking a,
it was a fun night.
It was a fun fucking night.
And uh,
you know,
and then afterwards everybody hung out and uh,
and I had these cigars that I brought and I was going,
I was saying to the people,
I say,
man,
we was there any place we can smoke these.
And one of the guys connected with the Bruins is like,
okay,
there's a room we can go to.
So we end up going to this like half locker room.
It wasn't a visitor locker room,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
And we went in there and we just let these things up and just told stories for
like fucking two hours.
The entire reason.
I love smoking cigars and we were in there so long,
by the time we got out,
like uh,
they had broken down the stage and everything and they were setting it up I
think for a Bruins game.
I couldn't tell if it was gonna be Bruins and Celtics.
It was sort of midway and just watching the bull gang or whatever they could,
they're called just set it up was so fucking cool,
are a little Uber fucking our little car service back to the hotel had left and
we were like,
yeah,
fuck it.
We were staying at the liberty so we just fucking walked around the corner and
uh,
it's fucking hilarious.
Just walking down the streets of Boston.
It fucking two in the morning on a Saturday night and every these fucking people
hammered almost a fight,
hear people screaming and yelling and shit.
And it's just like,
I dunno.
It's like God,
I remember this shit.
Fucking,
the energy of Boston is just,
it's so fucking unique.
It's really just like a,
I,
it took me a long time to pick up on it cause I was just in it.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of like if your car stinks when they see commercial where they say you
go nose blind,
you don't see it.
I kind of was like,
I dunno.
I couldn't see how fucking nuts Boston is,
but I've said it before.
Boston is like the sucker punch like capitol of the fucking world.
Like when you go into a Var,
you just add past a certain hour is this anger that settles it in the bar and
you just feel it.
Somebody getting fucking,
something's going to happen,
right?
You always say that dog hair about ob.
Ah,
dod got fucking sack in a bio last night.
Um,
some kids suck at,
I mean,
he was wearing a fucking claddagh ring kit.
I'm not saying it's all like that,
but there's just as that at two in the morning,
that vibe exist.
I remember one time walking back from the Wilbur theater,
I can't remember where the fuck I was staying.
I was walking with Zeros.
I was like,
man,
I'm man.
I just want to walk,
you know,
just walk the city a little bit,
man.
I missed it.
All the memories,
you know,
back in the day,
going to Emerson College and commuting and taking the train in to go to fucking
Bruins,
Celtics red sox games and shit.
And uh,
I was walking in like,
there was two of the angry fucking kids I've ever seen him in.
Like it was like these homeless people laying over the subway greats and they
will fucking walking by him and they would just screaming,
wake up,
get a fucking job.
Like they were like so angry.
They were like 30 yards in front of me and I was continuing to slow down cause I
was like,
if I'm even anywhere near this guy's orbit,
he's gonna want to fight me.
He was like that level of angry.
And of course his got his girlfriend who's trying to calm him down.
Oh my God,
stop it.
Just,
just go to the car.
What are you doing?
And he's fucking screaming and he's all fucking angry.
She's trying to fucking hold him and he's pulling away and shit.
So of course eventually he fucking sits down and he's just mean muggin everybody
coming by.
And I remember he yelled at me into Rosa and I'm just like,
just keep walking.
Just keep fucking,
just fucking,
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if it's in the water.
I don't know what that is.
But we felt that vibe and uh,
and it was funny.
So we were actually walking back was me,
Bobby and a couple of his buddies and I'm connected with the show,
right.
And we fucking walking back and uh,
we did that thing,
you know,
where it said don't walk.
And we were kind of standing in the street a little bit and these kids come
around the corner in this car,
the kid,
the jam packed with kids,
you know,
like everybody fucking pile did this kids fucking in the back seat.
He's got this awful fucking mustache.
It comes if you drive a bike,
yeah,
you're standing in this straight as he went by
and I could tell me and Bobby hadn't lived there in a long time and I just
looked at Bobby and I was just like,
you know,
we were standing in the street and he's like,
yeah,
he was right
now back in the day that would've been,
fuck you,
you fucking mustachioed whatever.
And then they would have pulled over and then you want to go,
oh,
you weren't fucking go.
And everybody's taking their gold chains off.
That was the eighties,
the eighties when he had gold chains.
And right before the fight,
everybody's like taking their gold shade off and handed it to your girlfriend.
Keep your rings on,
take your chains off dude.
Um,
yeah,
so it was always great to be back there and uh,
I didn't get to,
I came up to it so quickly.
I didn't get a chance to go to some of the old food haunts,
but my mother made some beef stew before I left,
so that was great.
I hung around for like a day,
like an asshole.
I hung around until like six at night thinking that I didn't look that thought
the Patriots game was a,
uh,
was an afternoon game.
But I got,
uh,
like I said,
I got to watch it on the,
uh,
on the um,
on the fucking ah,
on the plane,
on the airplane.
Nam.
Um,
so anyways.
All right,
let's get into,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
Um,
I have not watched the fucking Formula One race yet.
I know Lewis Hamilton won and he's closing the gap.
So you people who have not watched fucking Formula One all year.
I think the last one's in Abu Dhabi or some shit of Dubai.
I don't know where the fuck it is.
All right,
but this one is going to determine
the fucking window.
I think a Nico,
all these guys do is,
is just come in third place.
If he just does that,
he's going to win it.
And uh,
Louis obviously needs to win the fucking race,
but it's kind of cool that it's coming down to the last one.
Um,
anyways,
let me get to the fucking advertise.
I have to hum my pipe,
my password,
or else I won't be able to talk and fucking,
yeah,
here we go.
All right,
All right.
Oh,
on it everybody.
Joe Rogan's company a on it has a new product code.
It's called a mulcify MCT oil.
Mct Oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance or kickstart a weight
management program.
There are lots of MCT oil brands out there,
but there's none like emulsified MCT oil from Onnit available in three delicious
flavors,
coconut,
Vanilla,
and strawberry.
That's,
that's my DNA makeup.
Tell you this every week.
Oh my coconut at buy vanilla skating,
my strawberry pubes emulsified MCT oil like a mix.
It's like a cream easily in your morning coffee,
the need for a blender,
no mess,
no cleanup.
You can even mix it with your favorite into your favorite foods right now.
If you go to it.com/per,
you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's o n n I t.com/bill to get emulsified MCT oil for 12% off and for any
reason,
if you don't like it,
you'll get you.
They'll give you your money back,
no questions asked.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar and get on it.
You can tell that's Rogan's company.
He knows how short to make the copy.
Some of these fucking people,
they rent a Goddamn lovel.
Oh,
here's another one.
give me the loan Luke.
Create everybody can be the end,
the envy of all your nerdy friends and get 100% off exclusive
crates@lootcrate.com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription.
What is this?
This is a trunk full of Nerd Shit.
If you're into,
I'm just going to get to the point here.
If you're into movies,
if you're into action heroes or a superheroes,
right?
If you like taking a bath with some fucking rubber duckies in there,
these people got you covered.
All right?
You know,
you want to be that debt nerd at the party that fuckings got the fucking cool t
shirt,
but that obscure movie,
these are the guys,
these are the guys that are going to get that nerd chick to come walking up to
you right later on tonight.
You both take off each other's hooded sweatshirts,
um,
on a quest or you are on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
Um,
if you're more of a fantastic fanatical fashionista than try out Luke where this
is under no other copy in the world,
do I have no fucking idea what they're talking about.
Monthly wearables and accessories with cold classics in your favorite
franchises.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with the even bigger lute with loot crate DX.
Get ready for an Nov is enchanting theme magical.
Oh well,
the wonderful world of magic here in November,
loot crate has cast a powerful ancient spelled to deliver you.
November's crate featuring be witching items from Dr.
Strange,
fantastic beasts.
And where to find them.
I've never heard of any of that big trouble in little China.
I love that movie and so much more current Russell there when he fucking had the
lipstick on,
he was biting into that sandwich was fucking hilarious.
Uh,
do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for Novembers crate.
When it's over,
it's over.
No more crates.
Go to Luke,
crate.com/burr and enter my code bird to save $3 off on any new subscription
today.
Jesus Christ,
they're all nice and short this week.
This is fucking tremendous.
Can just plow right through them.
I think maybe the all got colt got together collectively.
It was just like,
we gotta help this guy out.
He's got to have an aneurysm trying to read out loud.
All right,
here's another one,
guys,
uh,
you know,
to go to dollar shave club for a fantastic shave,
guys,
this is why just bring you all in like we're all at a slumber party.
Uh,
what you probably don't know is that they have other amazing products to the
quality is the best on the market.
Their body wash is great and won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post shave stuff.
Keeps your skin soft and smooth.
There's stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks.
Dollar Shave club's got stuff for your hair,
for your face,
for your underparts.
The whole undercarriage there,
Huh?
They'll forget the lube it up,
right for anywhere,
for everywhere to keep you feeling and looking fresh.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see that they've got the best grooming products out there,
that they got a hot comb for your pubes and they're all affordable right now.
Right now's your chance to see for yourself why so many people love dollar shave
club.
If you're not a member yet,
and I've never joined,
now is the time.
You'll get your first month of razors for free.
Just pay shipping after that.
It's only a few bucks.
Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave club.com/.
Bar.
Um,
all right,
we've got,
what do we got?
Two more.
Alright.
Fuck that.
I'll,
I'll read those later.
Right.
Okay.
Back to the podcast.
So anyways,
um,
yes.
Why didn't get a chance to fucking race was in Brazil.
I got to taped at home.
I can't wait to see it cause it was raining.
And uh,
that's one of the coolest things I find about a formula one racing is that it's
like football.
They don't give a shit,
you know,
if it's raining or not,
they're going to keep that going to keep racing.
And uh,
I think that's cool.
Then adds all this extra elements to the race.
And um,
you know,
it's like when two teams like my team's favored by 14,
and all of a sudden it starts fucking rain and out.
Everybody started slip,
slide around.
You got yourself a good game.
I thought that this was going to be a landslide one way or the other.
Like Hillary Clinton.
I still can't believe Donald Trump won.
I still cannot fucking believe that.
Um,
a reality show TV star got fucking elected.
No Jj,
um,
to the worst fucking candidates ever to fucking face each others in my uncle
fucking opinion.
Boy,
what the fuck do I know?
Evidently I know a lot considering a lot of the fucking emails I got and all
this shit on Twitter.
I've got a lot of shit from my parents on loan,
uh,
Conant,
which I gotta be honest with you guys,
was not a fucking easy one to do.
It was the day after the election.
Everyone was in shock,
I think,
including Trump supporters because I went back east and I talked to a couple of
friends of mine and they voted for Trump.
And I was like,
dude,
I can't believe that guy wanted.
And they were like,
yeah,
I can't fucking believe it either.
So I dunno.
Maybe this is like when the Patriots beat the rams,
I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
that was not an easy,
uh,
an easy spot to be in,
you know,
and I stayed true to who I was and uninformed jackass who can't fucking read out
loud,
who's in conspiracy theory.
I talked about Hillary dressing up like a Yak and fucking people under a
mountain.
I talked about Trump being a dope and that whole ridiculous shit about building
a fucking wall.
I trashed them both equally.
But you know people who vote for colors,
right?
You got a blue tie,
you can say nothing wrong.
You got a red tie.
You can't do anything wrong.
Right.
I got so much fucking shit.
It's so amazing how people hear things.
I actually might point in all of that was like,
you know,
it'd be kind of cool if we all just stop yelling at each other.
All right.
If you guys,
if you want to hear my fucking theories,
this is my theory.
Okay.
I think Trump got in because of eight years of Obama and the progressive left
and I think they got in because of eight years of George Bush and I think and
Bush and Cheney and I think they got in because of eight years of Clinton and I
think Clinton got in because of 12 years of Reagan and Bush.
It just,
it just keeps,
it goes like way conservative.
And then it goes way fucking liberal and then it goes way conservative.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
think about where America was,
right?
Where when Bush and Cheney were there,
all right.
And then six years later or so during Obama's presidency,
like Bruce Jenner transitioned,
got her own show and was named woman of the year k.
Now that is not something that you would think could happen in oh seven,
six years later,
boom.
That's where the fuck it's act.
And I don't know.
And what I,
that's my problem with both sides is the way they ran their ideology down your
fucking throat.
And that if you have a difference of an opinion,
you know,
on the right,
it's usually,
it means you're against America.
You don't support the troops.
And a,
you're a socialist.
And on the left,
if you don't agree with them,
you're a cave man.
You're a fucking sexist.
You're a racist,
you're a homophobia or any of those fucking things.
Uh,
but both sides equally try to get you to lose your job.
And they try to destroy your ability to earn a living because of your beliefs.
And for the life of me as confusing as the prevent defense is,
can somebody please explain to me how if somebody says something politically or
socially that you don't agree with,
um,
spawning a movement to get them to lose their fucking job.
How that that person,
I'm more supportive of the troops.
America,
less of a socialist,
whatever the fuck it is you think they are or how that makes them less racist,
less homophobic.
Like,
um,
I dunno,
I I that doesn't work.
Yelling at people taking away their jobs.
You know what I mean?
It's like a way back when the Dixie chicks criticized George Bush the fucking
right.
All of a sudden they're there.
They pressured radio stations to not play their music.
They will do up fucking running over this cds with steam rollers and you know,
people like,
dude,
what the fuck you going a little far?
It's like,
no,
they had a right to say that we had a right to respond.
It's tit for tat.
It's like,
that's not tit for tat.
You know,
tit for tat is they trashed George Bush.
You defend George Bush and you trash them.
Trying to systematically destroy their career and their ability to make a living
is not tit for tat.
That's like somebody flicks you fucking ear and then you took out a fucking
knife and cut.
They're trying to cut the juggler.
So,
and personally speaking,
I think both sides are,
uh,
are really guilty of that.
They're really guilty when you get really far left and you get really far left
right there,
really guilty of just a bully people and they're so fucking wrapped up in that
they're so goddamn right about everything that they really become condescending
in sufferable assholes.
And um,
I dunno.
So I try to,
I try to stay in the middle cause I would never tell you who the fuck to vote
for,
nor did I ever on this thing unlike what most people saw.
Dude,
I got people on fucking Twitter.
It's hilarious.
Like they just sit in there.
First of all,
they think they know me because they watched me on a talk show and then they
think they know how I bought,
like the amount of people that dot.
I voted for Trump.
And then the amount of people that thought I voted for Hillary,
all the Trump people think I voted for fucking Hillary.
And all the Trump,
all the Hillary people think I voted for Trump.
I didn't vote for either one of them.
I told you guys right along,
Bernie Sanders was my fucking guy.
That was my fucking guy.
And watching him getting boxed out by the media because they felt Hillary had
more of a chance and they didn't give a shit that they would just voting just
more of the same,
more of the same.
MMM.
The only thing I will commend what the right is,
they got their Bernie Sanders in.
I mean,
the guy's a fucking shit show.
Yeah.
But at least,
you know,
at least they stuck by their rebel.
I wish that they had done that with,
I would have loved to seen Bernie against fucking Donald Trump.
I think Bernie would have had a better shot.
I just think the Clintons had too much fucking baggage,
you know?
And even as a Clinton supporter,
you know,
that's fucking true.
How little did Bill Clinton talked during that whole fucking time?
He didn't talk at all.
This is a former fucking president who had a successful presidency.
Immediate.
No,
he got impeached for sticking us to go lying about,
you know,
Monica Lewinsky.
He didn't talk like Al Gore lost to George Bush.
You know,
he didn't use Bill Clinton.
He goes,
I gotta get the fuck away from you,
dude.
You're a fucking nightmare.
You're a political fucking nightmare.
And the dude's on wife had to do the exact same fucking thing.
I Dunno.
They add a ton of fucking baggage,
you know,
and,
and Hillary supporters won't fucking look at it objectively at the same way
Trump supporters won't look at that.
I mean,
um,
I dunno.
It's just,
it's a fucked up time.
But I will tell you this though,
at the time for screaming and yelling at each other is over.
I feel,
and it would be nice is if those people who aren't crazy fucking left in crazy,
right,
could kind of maybe a break bread a little bit,
um,
which I don't think it's going to happen because um,
of eight years of Obama in eight years of progressive,
the progressive left becoming word police and uh,
and,
um,
social police and idea police and all of this stuff telling you what the fuck
you supposed to think about everything and what you're supposed to say and what
we're just supposed to use.
And I really think it's overly simplifying saying that the right voted the way
they did because they want to say homophobic and racial slurs.
Just turning people into it.
That's like both of them.
They always turn each other into like a cartoon.
Like you have even noticed like whenever like a Democrat gets in the right,
totally overreacts and like it's going to be socialism.
It's going to be like cognitives Russia.
There's going to be terrorists running down the fucking street,
you know?
And then whenever anybody in the right gets in,
it's always like,
this is like Germany in 1935 every fucking time they say that every fucking
time.
I'm not saying that one of those times it won't be fucking true,
but they say it every fucking time and they completely freak the fuck out.
And um,
I don't know.
And then when they get in,
they ran their ideologies down the other person's throat.
They have zero empathy for somebody else.
They have zero empathy for how,
uh,
people want to raise their kids and they just,
both sides.
They just like were 100% right.
And now you're going to fucking take this write down the throat and a,
I dunno,
they,
each election,
I think the pendulum keeps swinging father and father,
but even if you're not fucking Democrat,
you have to be proud of the last eight fucking years.
I mean,
at least there was no cigars and policies.
There was no,
uh,
they have weapons of mass destruction.
Oops,
we can't find any.
Oh,
now it's a liberation.
There was none of that shit.
Right.
Who knows who the fuck?
I don't know what's going to happen,
but uh,
you know,
I'm not comfortable with this result than anybody else,
but you,
you wouldn't know that from all these fucking things,
these emails,
these,
I'll read you two.
I'll try to get through these next two emails that I got.
This is classic
like political shit.
How people like,
they just hear what they want to hear,
right?
So this guy writes me in.
This guy is basically,
I think a blaming me in a roundabout way for Donald Trump getting in because God
knows that's the kind of power the Monday morning podcast has,
you know,
couple hundred thousand downloads.
I mean,
that's it,
dude.
That's it.
I can't believe I don't have secret service security right outside my door as I
do this.
I'm literally a podcast where I talk about fucking sports.
90% of the time I'll talk about conspiracy theory.
I say,
I'm an idiot.
I can't read out loud.
You know,
this guy for some reason is choosing to ignore all of this.
I'm going to say,
because the person he wanted didn't get in.
So here we go.
Dear freckles.
I'm no rocket scientist.
All right.
Immediately going self deprecating.
Neither are you okay.
Uh,
great.
And I think it's assume it's safe to assume the large majority of your listeners
aren't either.
Um,
unlike you.
I would never speak for them.
I don't know.
I don't know who they are.
Okay.
About,
you know,
if you want to assume that to continue on with your point,
I'll go along with it.
Most are like me,
average middle class person has not done one fucking ounce of research for this.
But this is,
this is,
this is how we build points.
This is how I build a point.
Most of like me,
average middle class folk who laugh like a laugh twice a week from our favorite
comedian say this.
This is laying the groundwork.
I feel an overhand right coming.
Uh,
you have swayed my opinion on several things over the years out.
Jesus,
most notably,
I went from a Patriot hater to someone who supports them and agrees they are
unfairly scrutinized by the league and other teams.
Isn't that amazing?
So I guess if I could sway you on the amount of air that should be in a
football,
I could sway you on who you're going to pick for the leader of the free world.
Yeah,
I can see that's the same.
You know,
I,
I totally see that point.
I don't think there's any sort of giant body of water that you're leaping over
there.
I don't know.
Okay.
Here we go.
When I realized,
when I realized how much your opinions of influence me,
I realized how much they might influence others.
Okay,
here's,
here's the big failure here buddy.
Okay.
You didn't agree with me on the Patriots.
I brought you around.
You didn't agree with me with my,
my political opinion on Hillary Clinton.
You didn't change.
You know,
I think that I can bring your fucking opinion around about using those Savy Save
,
fuck you fuck cards and your everyday bullshit life.
But when I think it comes down to electing the leader of the free world,
I think you go a little bit beyond the Monday morning podcast
or the Thursday afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast where I scream,
I'm just checking in on you like a fucking idiot for half a minute.
All right,
so here we,
here we goes with this dizzy,
he's laid.
See,
he came out,
I'm no rocket scientist.
Self deprecating,
okay.
Then he goes,
uh hey.
Now he just goes,
well,
I'm going to assume that this is what your listeners are without doing any sort
of research and then I'm going to go,
Oh,
you swayed me on this fucking basic bullshit horseshit.
That means actually nothing.
Therefore you could sway me on something.
That means you know
Jesus Christ to you walk through the mall and there's somebody sitting there
going,
hey buddy,
can I talk to you for a second?
This is a self fan.
Look at this.
You can spray some spreads her in and blah,
blah blah,
and I'll send you buy some little impulse buy thing.
Then then with your theory,
that guy could also get you to vote for who the fuck he wants you to vote for.
Anyways,
continuing on,
when I realized how much your opinion influenced me,
I realized how much they might influence others and how these influences might
have much larger implications than the NFL.
Call me crazy.
But it seems like you're going into paranoia now.
Um,
after your polls said that your person was going to win and now you're sitting
there with your jaw on the ground and now you're looking for escape goat in the
air.
I am a 48 year old bald,
pasty fucking red head.
There's an easy target.
Let's go after him.
I love it buddy.
Let's do it.
Fucking tar and feather me.
Here we go.
You have consistently and foolishly best bashed Hillary so much more.
So much more than you have Trump.
Hilarious,
right?
So much more than Trump.
I have an entire chunk of material on Donald Trump and Trump was so fucking
easy.
I felt guilty when I was on stage.
I did it when I was on Conan about building the fucking wall.
How ridiculous an idea that is,
how much money that was going to be.
I did all of that.
I always called them a dope.
I always called him a reality TV show.
Star didn't even remotely respect him as a businessman.
I said,
I didn't believe that he was a billionaire.
I don't think that he could get your six grand in cash if he gave him six or
seven weeks.
I thought he was completely leveraged out.
I made fun of his hair.
I made fun how we didn't say anything to anybody.
He never said anything.
It was the most fascinating thing I've ever seen.
He would go like,
fucking a,
I'm gonna do this.
I'm going to do that.
Some would be like,
how are you going to do that?
And we'd be like,
oh,
you'll see.
You'll see.
I was doing a bit in my ACO.
I want to use that with my wife.
Just make all these outrageous claims about what a great husband I'm going to
be.
And then when she gives me shit I,
well,
what are you going to do and improve yourself.
I'll,
you'll see.
You'll see,
no,
you need to tell me why I'm not going to give away my strategies,
then you'll steal them.
I did all of that.
Right.
And then Hillary,
I said that she was part of the Bilderberg group.
I talked about the Hillary Foundation and how they fucking been living off of
that shit.
They threw a $3 million wedding for their daughter.
All of that type of shit.
All over fucking felony charges and everything,
which of course,
all Hillary supporters are like,
those were unfounded.
They were not proven yet with fucking Donald Trump.
Six or seven people say that he sexually assaulted them,
which I fucking believe I believe that to that girl when she went get real,
which I also said on the podcast and I was like,
dude,
he definitely did that shit.
You didn't hear all any of this shit,
did you sir?
You know why?
Because,
because you got fucking blue tie stuck in your fucking ears.
All right,
let's go.
Continuing to blame me.
Alright.
Um,
I evidently got so much more,
I trashed Hillary,
uh,
the entire election.
You have unfairly focused hate on her.
And at the end of your tirade,
you tack on,
Oh,
and he's a cunt to uh,
you don't seem to realize the influence you have on people who listened to you
twice a week,
every week.
Sir,
you've done nothing to prove that I have influence.
This is,
this is all something that you built in your head when you are hyperventilating
that this fucking monster got into the office.
All right?
And Hillary's a month's to two.
Okay.
And that right there was my all when she's a con too,
I didn't like either one of these people.
And that was my message throughout all of this.
Okay.
And that's just my fucking opinion.
What's,
I'm allowed to have our night.
Alright.
You most likely,
you most likely influenced at least one voter to vote for Donald Trump.
And for that you should be fucking ashamed,
dude.
This is all fucking conspiracy theory.
Yeah,
because you chose,
you got somebody to cast one vote for the person that I didn't vote for.
You should be fucking ashamed because I only see the faults of the guy with the
red tie and I don't see any faults with the person with the Blue Blouse.
Alright,
you are a,
you are so stupid.
Here we go.
This is all be great to get somebody,
somebody to listen to your opinion.
Usually what she should do,
you usually should end with the insult.
Say your point and then you tag on your fucking ass hole because then they'll at
least hear your point.
But if you start to see if you've front end load,
all right,
you are so stupid that in one sentence you go from saying how they never talk
about this issue or that issue.
Then conclude by saying,
but I haven't watched any of the debates are kept up on this at all.
You fucking idiot.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
You don't think that Trump supporters didn't say the same thing they did buddy
cause I got the,
I have the exact same fucking email from the other side.
All right.
Which with my theory that I'll now use that also has no research behind it.
I would say that you guys all sort of canceled each other out.
So whatever influence I had,
I influenced somebody the other way too.
So I am completely exonerated here.
And if you look at the popular vote,
it was almost right down the fucking middle.
So there you go.
So you,
he calls me a fucking idiot.
All right.
Uh,
they never talk about climate change is something you've said on Monday.
the day before the election,
you have no clue what you're talking about.
Well,
first of all,
I said they never do.
I didn't say that one or the other.
So that was an even handed one,
right?
She goes,
click it.
Clinton has made it a major point and supports the Paris agreement.
Uh,
nothing I ever saw.
She made it a major point.
She's commented on it.
It goes to the Paris agreement.
Not that you even know what the fuck that is.
You freckled fuck.
Of course.
See this guy once again,
making assumptions.
I know what the Paris agreement is.
I've seen it on the daily show.
I saw when they all talked about it,
I saw when they went there in the right,
finally said,
and I actually talked about this on the podcast,
sir,
when the right went there,
then they finally said,
okay,
after denying it they finally said global warming does exist but it's too late
to do anything about it now.
All right.
I believe I compared that to when Pete rose finally admitted that he been on
baseball and said,
now can you let me in the hall of fame.
I distinctly remember saying that,
not that you remember that sir,
cause you got your blue bonnets stuffed in your fucking ear.
Right.
I also actually looked up weeks ago like when did people first start talking
about climate change?
As I was driving down the street and I was listening and they was saying,
you know,
I would drove,
drove down the street that morning.
I heard that on NPR they say,
scientists say the Great Barrier Reef is now dead.
And then they went on to talk about the cubs,
which is course struck me as funny that the whole rest of the report should have
been about that or that swirl a trash in the Pacific Ocean and all that shit,
which none of these guys really talk about.
They do a little bit of lip service,
that's about it.
But they're not going to fucking do anything about it.
And even if they try to,
they can't because these corporations own them,
which is why I like the fucking,
the lunatic guys.
I never vote for the fucking main people.
I don't know.
Whatever,
whatever.
Let's just plow ahead.
So anyways,
yeah,
I actually looked it up and the first time climate change is brought up,
somebody had like a theory before it was even happening was projecting that the
population kept growing,
that it was,
the theory was that we would heat up the plant and they did that in the early 18
hundreds I couldn't believe it.
And then there was a few more things about it.
I can't remember,
this was weeks ago,
but like in the late fifties was the first definitive papers saying since the
1950s,
scientists had been telling people that the pollutions and shit that we've been
putting in the air or whatever.
Like I'm not a scientist,
okay.
I am just a regular guy,
but I read,
they have known about it or had the attention called to it since the late 1950s.
Okay.
So I'm not as,
I am a moron,
but I'm not as dumb
as you think I am,
sir.
And one of the reasons why I underplay myself is because I don't want to be
another fucking jerk off
who's just fucking,
you know,
getting in your fucking ear like some people in my business.
Okay.
So anyways,
he goes,
uh,
Trump has said repeatedly that climate change is a hoax that was created by the
Chinese.
He said,
he said it repeatedly.
Um,
I'm going to look up the Internet,
see how many times he repeatedly said that.
Um,
usually when people say repeatedly,
it means it's a quote that somebody said like seven years ago.
Um,
one time.
All right.
And yet you blindly,
ignorantly spew your unfounded bullshit.
Dude,
you just define this podcast.
Why are you acting like this is meet the press?
He goes,
I'm not a genius.
Always back to being humble again.
I'm not a genius as you call me a fucking idiot.
All right.
I'm not a political scientist now.
He's doing humble pie.
He's got his hands up,
but I took just a few hours out of my life to research both of their positions
on crucial issues and get an understanding of them.
Oh yeah,
I never did that.
I didn't do that at all and I'm not the one speaking to thousands of people
twice a week.
You should truly be horrified at the thought you had anything to do with this
fucking train wreck.
I love how you your,
do you,
do you think that Hillary has any responsibility
for the campaign that she ran?
I mean from day one,
her campaign could not use an unbelievable asset,
which was former president,
Bill Clinton,
because of all of the shit show that that guy was both professionally and in his
personal life,
her husband,
it was a former president that was wildly popular.
She couldn't even use the guy.
Okay.
Because of all the fucking skeletons in his fucking closet,
you know,
and together they both had skeletons.
You know,
it's a very polarizing candidate that should pick.
And I thought in key moments,
you know,
where she really couldn't come up with something clever to say she didn't have
it.
Look,
sir,
be honest with me.
What really gets you into office,
your policy or playing the saxophone on fucking Arsenio Hall
are not sticking your head out of a tank and looking like a fucking dope or too
excited and going.
Yeah,
I mean,
that's the kind of shit that brings people down more so than anything else in to
,
that's not my fault.
If you want to fucking blame me for that,
but that is the truth.
So you can actually win an election.
Like,
he just saw that fucking dope Trump do without saying a fucking thing,
but being good at trash in somebody fucking shirt,
which is basically how he got in promising a bunch of shit,
not saying what he was going to do and then go look at that guy down there and
he's fucking clueless and everybody's just laughing.
Hillary didn't have any of that.
She had no fucking swagger.
She just do remember when she did that hot sauce moment on that fucking radio
show and uh,
the host was going,
everybody that was African American and she goes,
what's your favorite?
You know,
once you go to thing,
what are you always carry around with you?
And she said hot sauce,
which evidently was true.
Okay.
But immediately looked like she was pandering and the guy said,
are you just trying to pander?
Sounds to me like you just trying to pander to black people and rather than just
saying like,
Nah man,
I like it.
I've been blah,
blah,
blah.
She goes,
is it working?
Yeah.
Well that right did the,
why the fuck would you say that?
Why would you say it?
And when I saw her say that I immediately as soon as that she's,
she is pandering and then people will go in like,
well actually it's true.
And then I looked it up and I go,
oh it is fucking true.
But still,
this is the thing,
if I was really in the fucking hot sauce and I was fucking running and I was on
an all black radio station,
I wouldn't have brought it up cause it would've looked like pandering.
And then if I did bring it up,
sorry about my voice,
I sound like rode through puberty here.
Even if I did brought it up then I would have been honest about it.
But like,
no,
I know it sounds like a pandering,
but there are some crossover things.
I actually really enjoy it.
So
you mean you got,
you got,
she has to take some sort of the responsibility that,
you know,
she couldn't beat this fucking nitwit.
Um,
all right.
Over 300 of the top economists.
I'm not saying that she's not an evil to
over 300 of the top economists,
including eight Nobel laureates,
came together to say,
I didn't know if I said that right,
that a Trump presidency would mean turmoil in the American.
And as a result,
the world's economy,
over 350 of the best scientists in the world came together to say his presidency
would be a disaster for the entire planet because of his dangerous stance on
climate change.
Not to mention Russia literally threw a party in the polymer building as soon as
Trump was elected.
That actually I'm happy.
I like when Russia in the United States are unfriendly fucking terms.
It would be nice that we're not going in a direction to fucking keep pointing
missiles at one another.
MMM.
And you know,
for as much as,
uh,
Al Gore,
I loved his stance on climate change.
He wasn't able to get a fucking thing done.
He wasn't able to stop it.
He wanted to fucking,
uh,
you get a few policies in there,
they just ignore it.
And these guys are only in there for 48 years.
They just wait him out.
I remember when Al Gore want to have a car that got a hundred miles to a gallon.
I was excited.
I was in my twenties I wanted to buy the car.
They just kept delaying it and delaying and delaying it.
And then they got on office.
Al Didn't beat Bush and then they just scrapped it and it was fucking over.
And that's what they do because they don't give a shit.
They don't give a shit.
You honestly think Hillary Clinton would have stopped global warming if he
taught out of those 350 scientists that are all experts.
You know what else I've said?
They said it's too late.
It was too late by the 1980s it was [inaudible] or something on the 90s.
It's been too late.
It's fuck.
And it's almost like not even a fucking issue anymore.
Um,
I mean it is an issue,
but the only way to do it,
it was we would,
we would all have to fucking go back to live in like cavemen and on 90% of us
would have to die and just kind of sit there and not do jumping jacks to add to
the fucking heat and hope this think could heal itself.
Other than that,
I don't know.
What the fuck you going to do is everybody's running around just having to get a
flat screen TV and every fucking room.
You know,
I love how it's like the political candidates are responsible for,
it's like we're just as responsible as anybody else aren't we?
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
This is like meet the press here anyway.
So the next time you open that stupid fucking freckled crusted mouth,
this guy is like more enlightened than me by the way.
Remember your words have power.
You are an influential person whether you want to believe it or not.
I don't expect you to read this tide rate on the podcast,
but I hope you read it and realize what a fool you've been.
Why?
Cause I don't agree with you because you have all of this.
Admittedly,
that is,
none of this was researched.
If he just did 45 minutes of research.
Oh,
earlier you told me a couple hours,
you could see that.
Yes.
Hillary made mistakes with the email and been chassis.
Yeah,
she made mistakes.
Okay,
but nothing she ever did was criminal.
Exactly.
All right.
Well,
Trump,
he made some mistakes with women,
but none of it was ever criminal.
Or he would have been fucking in jail.
Right?
He would have been brought up on charges.
Right.
The charges would have stuck.
You can do the same thing.
You're going to completely and I how you don't bring up the fucking Hillary
Foundation or anything,
that type of shit either or any of the other fucking,
all that other,
whatever,
the fucking Whitewater,
all of that fucking crap.
You don't bring up any of that shit.
You know,
bring up the fact that they're both worth hundreds of millions of fucking
dollars,
and that's not a red flag to you.
These down to Earth Democrats too.
What were men of the people?
They're worth a couple hundred million dollars.
The president's seat pays 500 grand a year.
How do they do it and don't give me that horse shit about,
they give political speeches,
fucking political speeches that they give.
Okay,
can you at least agree with me on this,
sir?
That is just,
that's just those people washing their bribe money.
Those are the people that put them in office and then they go back and they give
a speech and they give them 300 grand,
250 grand to fucking speak there for it.
Give me a fucking break.
All right.
All right,
so there,
that's his fucking thing.
So he thinks I'm a moron and I got Trump to be fucking elected.
Okay enough.
Now here's somebody's exact opposite a bill.
You really are uneducated on Trump built.
You need to run away from the progressive's.
This person thinks I'm a progressive liberal.
Listen to the exact same podcast,
sir.
Move the fuck out of California or whatever liberal spot you're living in.
Now,
this is what I can tell you immediately is the last person who wrote this email
is not listening to this at all.
It's just,
it's already yelling at his fucking windshield about what a dope disguise.
He goes.
I just heard your podcast about your the tearful Democrats.
Yeah,
he listened to my podcast and he thinks that I'm a progressive liberal and for
instance,
you had no clue who is going to pay for the wall.
Dude,
I've said all along,
I have no clue.
I don't know shit about football.
I watch fucking patriots,
Seattle.
I can't name half the fucking people.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
you have no true,
this is the funniest thing I've ever,
one of the funny things I've read,
you have no clue who's going to pay for the wall.
Trump had a hundred rallies where he,
he asked the audience,
who's going to pay for the wall and everyone would shout Mexico.
Do you realize,
sir,
that all you were doing was just repeating what he said was going to happen,
but he never said how we would get Mexico.
Sir.
Just imagine you didn't like your next door neighbor.
Okay?
And you were sick of him cutting across your lawn or whatever the fuck he was
doing.
You know,
cutting across the corner your lawn and making the grass go flat and you were
fucking sick of it.
Now let me ask you this.
Let's say you decided to build a wall and you decided that he was going to pay
for it.
How would you go about doing that?
Exactly?
Now let's move it up to a fucking country level.
So we're going to build this wall and we're going to,
how will we,
how is he going to make Mexico pay for it?
And if you tell me it's only a guest,
cause as far as I watched,
he never said how
economic sanctions,
you're going to pressure them into fucking doing it.
Okay.
Anyway,
so here we go.
How is it that those mobs mobs,
great word Dude are more educated than you.
Who the fuck is saying that the benefit of the walls will be jobs?
Who are you listening to and who said Trump doesn't want health care?
He's been really left on healthcare saying people with no insurance should be
able to get treatment and care from way back when he was running in the
primaries.
Seton to this guy thinks Trump is left on this seat.
This is why.
This is why sir,
the first person that you think I had influence,
it's like people just hear the podcast.
You guys already have your fucking minds made up and then you listen to the
podcast,
okay?
And you,
it's like watching a football game and you're listening to Chris Collins worth,
I met him one time when I did inside the NFL.
Chris Collins worth goes,
everybody thinks I hate their fucking team and like the other team better and
this will,
that's what you guys are doing with this podcast.
All right?
You guys are listening to this shit.
You lean left or you lean right?
And when I trashed your guy,
you think I'm only trashing your,
your man or woman and I'm,
and I'm trashing it more than the other people.
And then if and when you're a person loses you then blame my podcast.
All right?
You guys went out and you voted for who the fuck you wanted to vote for,
and you listen to the information that you wanted to listen to and you listen to
whatever the fuck you were receptive to that vibe in your life,
which is the exact reason why when I,
I was still in this band on stage talking about Trump's support is going,
how can you support this guy?
He's got people openly yelling the n word
at his rallies.
There's video of that.
Doesn't that bother you?
And this is what they would say.
Well,
you know,
I'm not,
I've said this on Conan.
There'll be agree.
No,
I'm not.
I'm,
no,
I'm not into that.
I'm not doing that.
But Hillary,
and what it is,
is what tracks for people is what's going to affect their fucking life.
And unfortunately,
when it comes to fucking racism,
it doesn't track with white people because it's not a factor in their life.
Why people are not victims of racism,
despite the fact they say that they are,
when they talk about like affirmative action,
that that's racist because they don't understand that the reason why affirmative
action came about was because racist white people would not hire people who are
not white.
So they literally had to come up with the law to force white people to give
other people a chance.
And then what people do is they just look at that moment.
They don't look at the history of it.
They just look right then and there.
So I dunno,
I think that,
look,
I understand that right now.
Believe me,
do I understand going to comedy shows and seeing the way the fucking crowd is
reacting,
that this is a very volatile fucking time.
Um,
this guy goes on to talk about how fucking,
uh,
people thought Republicans were being dramatic when they said no to world war
three vote Trump,
but the democratic national,
the DNC,
I don't know what the fucking stands for force Russia to,
uh,
why is it a DNP Democratic National Party,
make my life easier.
Force.
Russia didn't dump tons of money into hypersonic nuclear missiles.
They have these fucking hypersonic characters that can hold 16 nuclear warheads
that they can penetrate our missile shields,
uh,
blah,
and all this type of shit.
A reputable scholars were saying that moving towards,
we're moving towards world war three.
If you elect Hillary now,
they're all changing their tune,
thanks to president Trump,
former host of the apprentice.
Get on board with Trump.
You're annoying.
Voice should be on our side,
so he doesn't think I'm fucking on his side.
You don't think I'm on your side?
Both of you have scholars and scientists that say your point of view was right
because what you guys do is you go to [inaudible] dot com and you memorize a
bunch of horse shit and then when your person doesn't win you then fucking blame
a podcast.
So there you go.
I don't know what to tell you guys.
I respect both of your opinions.
I don't agree on either one of them.
I usually don't say who I vote for because I think it's a private matter.
But I did not vote for either one of them.
I voted for,
I voted for somebody else.
Bernie wasn't on the ballot.
I voted for somebody else that I thought was the best candidate,
not who the fuck I thought was gonna win.
And I think that's a major problem is that people don't want what's right.
They want to win,
you know,
so they will go with a candidate that is a warmonger or a fucking racist or a,
or a corrupt piece of shit.
And they don't give a fuck as long as they're wearing the right fucking color
tie.
All right.
And I want it done.
Um,
all right,
let's do some advertising.
Everybody.
Um,
but I do have to say this is,
let's just say whatever Trump is gonna do.
Um,
all it's doing for me,
you know,
he appoints this guy and he's got this fucking past where he allegedly said
something about Jews,
you know,
wasn't proven or whatever,
but he's got this fucking background.
Like all that does for me.
It's just inspires me to become more of a fucking understanding person and try
to listen to people.
And as long as you just take that,
like,
that attitude,
you know,
I,
I don't really don't think a president should,
um,
make up your mind on who you should be afraid of
in what we need to do and what these people are going to do to us and what
they're not going to do to us.
Just cause they fucking said it.
I don't,
I don't listen to that.
What I like to do is I listened to the,
what the president says,
and then I go to the country and I go to the fucking thing and I try to find
some English story about what the fuck they're saying about us.
And then I try to,
to figure out what the middle is.
All right.
I don't know.
I don't give a shit.
What color you fucking tires.
All right?
So white people,
if you're nervous,
okay.
Liberal whites,
if you're really a fucking good liberal white,
you'll become even more fucking understanding of people that aren't white and,
and,
and debt are gonna,
you know?
Hmm
bear the brunt of what this guy might fucking do.
I think it's your responsibility to become even more understanding.
You know what I mean?
And stop making everything about yourself in your fucking world because the
mainstream is already about that.
All right.
There you go.
I'm off my game.
Take a ticket or don't you know it's up to fucking you.
All right,
but I don't want you to,
I don't to hear you crying about fumbling.
Somebody taking your fucking,
I can't stand.
Listen to white people talking about,
oh,
they're taking the country away from us.
It's like if you looked at a fucking census,
you idiot.
You know?
If you find all the waterparks they're made for you don't want gives us a second
look when you show up like what's,
what's his element doing here?
They're excited you there and within two seconds to someone in a mascot outfit,
fucking hugging you.
There you go.
All right,
you're going to be fine.
All right.
Drive in your four wheeler on your property.
MVMT watches.
Everybody pronounced movement was founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
With over 500,000 watches sold to customers and 160 plus countries around the
world,
MVMT watches has solidified itself as the world's fastest growing watch company
movement watches start at just $95 at a department store.
You're looking at a good four to 500 bucks moving watches figured out by selling
online,
they are able to cut out the middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price.
Over $500 thousand watches sold in over 160 countries.
Uh,
get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/burger.
That's MVMT
watches.com/burr.
Uh,
this watch has a really clean design.
I always hate this part.
It's like you already sold them.
How are you going to come back around again?
This watch as a really clean design seriously.
Um,
evidently had been kind of been getting compliments ever since I put it on.
I not only am I not wearing it,
I actually lost my other watch.
It's a nice fucking watch.
Okay.
I didn't wear it because I have other watches,
you know,
because I'm in my forties and I can afford a nice watch.
So I bought that one off.
I was on my twenties.
I'd fucking by this one.
All right,
go to MVT.
MVMT watches.com/bar joined the movement,
but I didn't buy an overly expensive one.
I do not understand buying a super expensive fucking watch.
I just don't get it.
All right.
I don't understand it.
They'll just end up telling the time,
right?
I mean,
this is the Kinda guy drove a Prius for nine years,
right?
I should have a movement.
Watch.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
some small businesses still think an expensive postage meter is the only way to
get postage without having to go to the post office.
But they're wrong.
There's stamps.com with stamps.com you can easily print postage for any letter
or package using just your computer and printer.
Uh,
no extra hardware to buy.
No longterm contracts.
stamps.com conserve you at least 50% compared to a meter plus.
You can do more with stamps.com and you can with the meter,
like sent package tracking information to to receipts with one click.
The choice is clear.
stamps.com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I've been using [inaudible] dot com for years for my show.
It makes mailing and stay on shipping really convenient.
Right now.
Sign up for stamps.com use my last name.
Burdekin four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and digital.
Stay at scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Burger.
Uh,
that's it.
All right,
cool.
All right.
Anyways,
that's sort of the podcast.
He has another thing like,
um,
you know,
I travel a lot so I get to talk to all of these fucking people out there and uh,
I know somebody that voted for Trump and was like,
I think it's exciting.
I think it's exciting that he's going to be president.
Obviously he's a white dude.
He's excited,
right?
And this is the same guy.
He said,
Obama is a fucking idiot.
All right.
Which you're free to say that you think he's a fucking idiot,
but you can watch the fucking Donald Trump.
I'm going to do it.
It just,
it just,
I don't know.
That's what I learned traveling this country.
It's just people here.
What the fuck they want to hear.
Um,
alright.
Lingerie.
Let's,
let's get off politics.
I'll give you guys a breather here.
All right.
But,
uh,
please guys,
just stop fucking yelling at each other.
All right?
It's just stop blaming everybody and just fucking human beings here.
All right.
Let's be honest with you.
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton are not out for you or for me.
They're out there for themselves and that's why they're worth hundreds of
billions of dollars.
Make no mistake.
All right?
Fucking show up in a radio station with the hot sauce for fun just during the
campaign and where the fuck you going to be the rest of the time you're going to
be in the White House buying up fucking land on aquifers.
All right.
Hey,
Billy nipple slip.
I recently started dating this girl and we've been messing around for a few
months now.
Congratulations.
She's pretty cool and a really sweet girl and sex is great with them.
Alright,
Trifecta,
however,
she's been doing a lot of lingerie shopping and wants me to go with her one day
so we can shop for her lingerie together.
Uh,
personally I never got the point of lingerie nor I am am I a big fan of it?
I'm really you just like when they just show up with like your fucking old
basketball shorts on one of those guys.
As long as there's a pussy underneath it,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Personally,
I never got the pocket.
Didn't see the point of buying something that was meant for you to take off
almost immediately after you put it on.
All right sir.
This is the thing about,
all right,
so you're a,
you're a,
you're one of those no foreplay guys.
All right.
If you really want to take it to the next level too,
like you have,
you ever make a meal for somebody and you set it down and you turn your back to
the stove to set the pan back down.
And when you look back,
they were already halfway done with it and you're like,
what the fuck did I do all that work for?
Um,
I would let her buy that.
It makes her feel sexy,
right?
And then,
you know,
gets,
get all,
even into the,
you know,
the mood a little bit more telling you do it.
Yeah.
You're striking me as somebody who never takes the downtown six,
if you know what I mean.
It's fucking rips the clothes off,
puts her on her back,
fucking rolls off Ben in it,
then it turns on the fucking TV.
All right?
Also,
I'm not that great at faking my reaction when her or a girls have broke out
those sexy lingerie and I'm unenthused by it.
You know what,
dude?
Uh,
you're an asshole.
You really are an asshole.
Um,
and that can be a good thing.
You can,
you're going to get what you want in life,
but a,
you're going to miss out on a lot in life.
Um,
it's even given,
got me in a great,
got me in trouble a couple times.
The girls I've been dating for the most part have been pretty sexy,
but when it comes to lingerie,
I just think it makes things awkward.
That is the most overused word on the planet.
It's the default emotion of these,
this entire fucking world.
Now,
I don't even know what the word means anymore.
It's been applied to everything.
Everything's awkward.
I don't know what that means.
Same goes for things like sexting,
roleplaying,
Vage and tit pics and anything else that's kind of puts you on the spot for
things involving sex.
Is it weird that that stuff does nothing for me?
No,
it isn't,
but it shouldn't make the other person feel like an asshole.
Uh,
should I try to do my best to I,
you know what I preempt?
I shouldn't have called you an asshole this early cause now you're asking
questions.
All right.
I apologize.
I'm wrong.
All right.
I should,
should I try my best to continue pretending that my wiener isn't shriveling up
like a sock when you pull the strings up,
the strings out of it.
Oh,
the lingerie.
Huge fan of the podcast.
I haven't,
if you haven't yet,
please come out.
I'm not going to say where he's from just in case his fucking girlfriend
recognizes this.
Um,
you know,
do,
you could just kind of go along with it a little bit.
Like,
look,
I think like just saying you're not into sexting and in,
in,
in role playing and shit.
That's like next level shit.
If you're not into that,
that's fine.
Okay.
Um,
lingerie I think is a simple thing you could put a happy face on.
I mean,
as much as guys think the lingerie's for them and for the most part,
the way women dress,
like guys,
old little girl,
she's odd.
She wants it.
I mean that dress it for themselves.
They like to look pretty.
All right.
That makes them feel good.
So I think the Lang Nia,
can you come in for a second?
She's given me a look here.
Come here.
Oh Jesus.
She literally walked by,
stopped and look at me.
All right,
so this guy,
this guy is a,
Oh my God,
it's 10 36 I've got to get off my fucking day.
So this guy,
could you look less enthused?
Yeah,
you shot me a look.
I thought that meant you wanted to come in.
I'm just listening,
but go on.
What do you Henry Hill.
I'm just listening.
Do you want me to say then my wife?
Two Times.
Me.
All right,
so this guy,
he's got this great girl.
She's fucking cool.
She's sexy,
sexist,
great,
but she's into wearing sexy lingerie.
It does nothing for him.
She wants to fucking him to go along on it and like he thinks it's just stupid.
So she puts it on and she fucking pulls the strings like Badadada.
Bu when he said,
I'm supposed to sit there and act like my Dick.
Dick is not shriveling up like a sock.
What's,
what should I do?
He don't think,
he doesn't think lingerie is sexy.
He's just done it.
He goes,
I don't understand the point of just buying that and on.
I'm just going to take it off like two seconds later.
Okay.
It makes her feel good.
Just go along with it.
It's not going to kill you.
That's my advice.
Yeah,
it's,
it's just,
just go along with it.
It's now he said,
what about like sexting Vage and titty pics?
He goes,
I'm not into any of that or role playing.
You are so boring.
Whoever wrote this in,
I use really just,
it's like a job fucking prude and you're so boring.
Like loosen up a little bit.
Send a dick pic to your girlfriends.
No,
that's a bad idea.
Yeah.
I mean you probably shouldn't.
Yeah,
you never,
you don't,
you never sent any of that shit because it exists forever.
Yeah.
He'd be the one person.
It would come back to haunt him somehow.
So maybe don't do that,
but just open your mind a little bit.
It sounds like you're in a little sexual box and maybe you need to,
no pun intended,
you need to break out of this box.
But here's the thing,
explore something different.
And you know,
here's the thing on the Dick Pic,
Nia.
Okay.
People think,
okay,
I'm going to send a dick pic to you from my phone to your phone.
[inaudible] just think of the journey that thing takes.
My Dick goes to outer space.
Yep.
Goes off a satellite and it comes back down.
God knows how much shit is between that and that.
I mean,
how many miles that thing just travel and to think that that's just going to go
there.
And then if you're on like Twitter or do they say like,
can we want permission to have access to your photos?
And I,
I never say yes.
It's like you can have access to this photo.
[inaudible] you know?
Yeah.
I mean all of a sudden somebody,
you know,
you have to see your avatars,
your dick pic on set into somebody else's Avatars,
your Dick Pictures,
deck peg,
delete the deck pack and then ask that person to delete the dick pic to,
no,
you'd never sent pics.
I gets down.
Send Ben.
Period.
What you do is say,
where are you?
I'll show it to you live like in the old days in color,
you know,
like the old days,
the satellite Dick Pics.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
in terms of this guy,
I think he should just kind of open his mind a little bit.
Like I said,
it seems a little loop brutish and that's fine.
You don't have to like lingerie and all that,
but I mean,
if your girls into it and you like her and she likes lingerie,
like what's the problem?
You know,
just,
I guess it's not,
I don't see any problem with how do you know,
like lingerie?
I don't know.
That's what I'm saying is boring as fuck.
He's saying he wants to show up wearing his basketball shorts.
He's just like,
just be naked.
That's what I was saying.
You know,
I was comparing it to like,
you know,
when you're cooked somebody a meal,
then they eat it in two seconds.
You just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Like you do?
Huh?
But not in the bedroom.
Oh,
I do wolf down food Edm.
Huh.
But that's not the only thing you will forget.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Nia,
why would you say that?
No,
that's disgusting.
You take your time,
a woman in New York and your condition,
my condition.
Then your conditioned speaking this way.
That's terrible.
What if other people were to hear it?
I know.
Um,
what would they think?
All right.
That's the podcast here.
That's it.
Oh,
oh no.
Well you got me here now.
Well,
I got to go edit my special.
I got to see how my,
especially at [inaudible] where I trashed both Hillary and Trump and still get
shit for it.
Yeah,
no and then Trump can't win.
You can't win.
And that's why I never,
I don't tell people who to vote for and I,
I,
I mean it is like,
you know,
it's going on,
so I'm going to fucking talk about it because it's fun.
It's fun to shit on them.
Yeah.
But like I think this one,
people are so upset that they,
that their person didn't get in that now they're looking to blame.
So evidently the Monday morning podcast has the ability to sway a presidential
election.
Right.
Well,
you know,
you do have a platform and you have to use it responsibly.
I'm going to start using this platform.
I think it's time.
Everybody buys me a new car.
This will be good for America.
Yeah,
that's,
it's completely ridiculous.
People know who the fuck they're going to vote for.
Yeah.
And then it just needs,
just needs some time to,
I dunno.
I don't know if anyone's ever going to be fully okay with what just happened,
but oh,
Trump supporters are totally over there.
Great.
That totally okay with it.
Good right now.
Yeah,
but oh well
I'm glad she's fucking gone,
but I'm not happy that he's here.
There was an,
there was a lose lose
situations.
Definitely depressing.
No matter how you slice it,
it's fucking depressing.
But life goes on.
It has to.
Yeah,
and you know something.
I don't think people should just fucking,
like it says it doesn't change who you are going to be as a person.
Yeah.
I think if anything,
you just do what people are saying.
You stay here and you'd pay attention to what's going on and you support the
causes that mean a lot to you and just put all your effort behind that.
I feel like that's the way to like really make change.
Should you not move to Canada and no,
they don't want us.
I,
that was another funny thing too where they all acted like that they were going
to be so accepting.
Yeah.
That doesn't fucking want us like an Elec how I feel like it's really arrogant
to just be like,
oh,
I'm just going to move to Canada.
Canada's like,
okay,
do I have any say in this?
Like why do I become the place that you come to after your country made a horror
?
I know,
but these are,
these are some of the great artistic minds on the planet would be gracing their
country with their songs and their standup.
They should be happy.
They should welcome them with open arms.
Well,
you know the ones I like the celebrities we'd like.
Today my heart is tonight,
my heart cries,
but tomorrow I fight and they get the little fucking muscle thing there.
It's like you'd probably go to your personal trainer first.
I would think.
Maybe have your personal chef make you
guilty of that.
I put on Twitter that I cried,
but I felt hopeful because I did.
I've never cried after an election before and I did,
but I'm done crying.
I'm over crying and uh,
I'm ready to move forward.
And you go,
you can,
I'm just picturing somebody crying with their fucking downtown to ocean views.
What's going to happen to me?
Um,
yeah.
Isn't it like mid term elections?
If some come up like a year and a half or something like that,
then it's going to go the other way.
We'll see what happens in four years.
If he gets reelected or somebody else comes up.
I don't even know how,
I didn't even understand how the process works.
Honestly.
Keeps throwing that out there cause I didn't know.
He said fucking Clinton support.
Bernie ran again and four years.
Do you think?
No,
Bernie cannot win because he's not owned by the same seven corporations that you
need to be owned by.
I'm just throwing seven out.
Then he comes back and he runs in four years against Trump.
I would say the media will,
the left media,
we'll fucking take them out again.
They'll take,
but can he win?
Can you really win?
That's what they did.
They fucked him over.
They fucked him over and they left us with this polarizing person and then she
fucking lost.
And now people are all going,
what the fuck happened?
And they're blaming podcasts.
It's my fault.
Trump got in also.
It's also my flat.
Have you done this?
This fucking Trump supporter guy goes like,
you sitting there talking about the cost of wall.
How can you be so ignorant about the costs of the wall?
He goes to mobs of people that show you that must have been I,
it's so fucking dumb.
I actually think somebody,
uh,
democratic supporters sent it and he said,
every time he said,
who's going to pay for the wall,
the whole mob would yell Mexico.
Like,
how can you be so dumb that you didn't realize that?
Now that I'm saying that again,
I think that that,
I think someone was trolling me there.
I can't believe someone was that done
well,
but Trump said that he was like,
we're going to build a wall and Mexico's going to pay for it.
I know.
Who would be dumb enough to think that you can make another country pay for your
shit.
We're going to build a wall to keep you out and a,
you're going to pay for it.
I would say that would be like if you're negative,
you didn't like your next door neighbor and you built a wall.
Then you sent them a bill.
Maybe you'd be like,
ah,
make a paper airplane and just throw it back over.
I have no idea how he plans on enforcing that.
I guess we'll see.
You know what I do love is the f the first lady has fake tits.
I thought they worked.
It were just to round.
How would we,
how would you possibly know that?
I don't know that and yeah,
I don't know anything.
I mean,
I've said that for fucking years.
Yeah,
that's true.
He has put it out there that he's got,
he's got the president as a trophy wife.
Fucking hilarious.
He's on his third one.
Hey,
if you fucking act up,
don't even think you're going to be,
you're going to be sitting here picking out plates during my second term lady.
His wife like doesn't even,
I don't know,
she doesn't even like register for me.
I mean,
yeah,
she's beautiful and all that,
but I don't really care.
I liked that she plagiarized Michelle Obama's speech,
which I think is really related to the millennials,
the way they curate,
you know,
Shit that they didn't do onto their Facebook pages and youtube pages and fucking
make all this money off of stuff that they didn't really do.
Oh,
you mean like sharing of memes and things,
sharing of standup specials and music and videos.
Shit that they didn't do and they just take it.
Oh,
I thought that was very millennial.
Her grandpa.
Was that what the young people do?
Yeah,
that is what they do.
Oh,
I fucking hate her.
You just exonerated all of them from stealing all that shit.
Those specials cost me a bunch of fucking money and everybody just takes them
steal your special and or downloaded illegally.
Of course,
I don't believe that they should do.
Then you have to understand that you have a platform on this podcast and all of
those people that were already doing it anyways,
there's now a bunch of others that are now going to do it.
Cause you said it was okay.
Hey,
you know what's weird is the windscreen is red.
Maybe I am a Trump supporter.
Oh,
maybe so maybe that was a subconscious decision on your part.
I liked the orange one,
but cleo aided double minded me.
A fucking ABC's wide world of sports with Jim Mckay.
Who knew you were an elephant.
You seem like a jackass to me.
Nothing.
Oh,
I didn't get it.
I didn't get all that.
Those are the animals,
right?
Jesus Democrats are really donkeys.
Why would they pick that?
I don't know.
There's a reason behind it.
We just haven't Wikipedia it,
googled it,
whatever.
Well,
I'm sure someone will tell me why.
Preempting it.
Hey,
you fucking moron.
I'm all right.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
I'm sorry for Donald Trump.
Um,
next time I will try to,
uh,
I haven't made up my mind who I want to be president yet.
Uh,
the next time I think I'm already over Trump and,
uh,
I'll,
I'll figure it out.
Yeah,
I hope so.
So this doesn't happen again.
You fucking election and rigor.
You regular.
You all right?
That's it.
I gotta I gotta fucking upload this shit.
I gotta go edit.
My goddamn specialist is going to be the worst fucking thing ever.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.